the Democratic Party experienced a
seismic shock last night when in the New
York City outer boroughs a 28 year old
political novice primary Dhin defeated a
member of the Democratic leadership
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez ended the
20-year run of Congressman Joe Crowley
who many thought would succeed Pelosi as
a Democratic leader so he raised three
million dollars in the race Ocasio
Cortes about 300,000 by now you may have
heard some of the bullet points here
she's a member of the Democratic
socialists of America who is it she
supports publicly funded trade schools
and universities well she worked for Ted
Kennedy and Bernie Sanders she's called
for the abolishment of immigration
Customs Enforcement otherwise known as
ice
now Ocasio a cortez even went down to
the border a few days ago to protest the
Trump immigration policies in an
interview today haha the i-word came up
I would support impeachment I think that
you know we have the grounds to do it on
what grounds for the president be
impeached well I think that there are
serious grounds and violations of the
emoluments clause from day one who the
emoluments clause so we go to Wikipedia
for that well look come on that's a
typical left-wing moveon.org blather but
here's what you need to know Ocasio
cortez is a disrupter from the far left
wing of the Democratic Party
I mean she's attractive she went all in
and you got to give her credit for what
she did and this is what happens when a
political establishment fails to deliver
results and refuses to listen to its
people its base election after election
now remember when the democratically
Debbie wasserman-schultz did she had and
Hillary Clinton conspired to keep Bernie
Sanders from winning the nomination and
all you have to do is take a look at
WikiLeaks and just see what they said
about Bernie Sanders and see what Debora
Simon Schultz had in mind because Bernie
Sanders between super-delegates and
Debra Wasserman Schultz he never had a
chance oh it's so smart for Trump to
bring that up now let's not forget all
the energy during 2016 it was with
Sanders he filled more stadiums he was
more passionate was always about the
working class and he excited more young
people than Hillary Clinton ever could
but then we stirred up the Democratic
base the establishment they put him down
well you can only do that for so long
until your voters Rebell which is what
they did against Crowley last night I
think what it should tell the American
people is that when you have candidates
like Alexandria will have the guts to
talk about the real issues impacting
people's lives she campaigned on health
care as a right not a privilege they'll
win in New York City they won in
Maryland was seeing this happening all
across the country okay
this upset in New York last night it was
a liberal party faithful acting out
against the Democratic leadership for
their ineffectiveness it's also a
not-so-quiet admission let's face it
that Trump he's winning on most every
front and he's been able to steamroll
the Democrats on key issues the
Republican Party let's not forget though
they experienced its own wake-up call
back in 2014
now Eric Cantor remember he was ousted
by that barely known econ professor
named Dave brat and then Speaker John
Boehner was ushered into retirement not
long thereafter
well now the Bell is tolling for Nancy
Pelosi former speaker for the Democrats
who was questioned about last night's
stunning upset
laughing they are progressive
Republicans say one of the things the
study shows is that democratic socialism
is a sentient being or a party are they
right no descendant in that district
perhaps other Democratic stalwarts like
Maryland gubernatorial candidate former
n-double-a-cp chair Ben Jealous were
also pressed today about a possible sea
change in the party what is your thought
on Nancy Pelosi sitting at the helm of
your party yeah again you're not wait
were there two beats with that pause I
love that moment well look I'm like
Democrats Republicans were not at a loss
for words but cheered the route from the
left it was a stunning development the
energy and the Democratic Party is
self-avowed socialist open borders we
even had a credible potential candidate
for president in 2020 suggest we get rid
of ice the border enforcement agency I
think the Democrats are going hard left
well when I said cheering that's Mitch
McConnell style cheering before
Republicans those start popping the
Cork's there is a lesson here for them
as well think about it this way if
Republicans start walking back from the
Trump agenda walking away from it if
they get wobbly or try to defuse the key
policies that Trump won on but he ran on
danger lies ahead Republicans today
failed to pass another immigration bill
and this after they rejected the
congressman Goodlatte bill that was the
most faithful in the best as far as the
original Trump agenda when it's really
stupid meanwhile the White House backed
off threats to strictly limit Chinese
investment in US tech companies another
disappointment
although at least Beijing and Wall
Street were happy
and despite preliminary data indicating
a downturn in arrests at the border this
month the government has reverted at
least for the time being and I had a
district court judge push them to do so
they've had to revert to this catch and
release policy for illegal immigrants
who enter the country with children so
that's frustrating I'd be very careful
if the voters start believing that
you're abandoning the core policies they
elected you to advance they'll remove
you from office no matter how much they
initially liked you and no matter how
much Senor do you have and when the
Democrats stir up young voters as Ocasio
Cortez did last night
promises promising them the moon a host
of freebies how are Republicans going to
respond how do they message the
conservative populist agenda that's so
smart and so right for younger voters
disruptors correct create political
opportunities for both sides but their
unexpected victories also carry warnings
for those who attempt to conduct
business as usual Trump so far isn't
doing that but on the few issues we have
to keep a very close watch and that's
the angle